how do you think life originated on
Earth we've talked about this a bit do
you have a gut feeling about first of
all actually even to step back do you
think because you were like flirting
with this idea is the translation
mechanism came before life
I think that you cannot separate from
translation emergence of translation
Machinery from immersions of life or
something like translation missionary
this whole informatic chemical Computing
system that is also capable of dynamism
and evolvability that comes with Biology
biological behavior from emergence of
life itself we've definitely
took a lot of steps towards
understanding Origins we are able to
create molecules from
right
environments lightning Heat
and you make amino acids so we are able
to create the building blocks the Miller
Yuri experiment
that's Now 60 years ago
we are able to create the building
blocks we are able to make them interact
with one another they can get more
complex some call this messy there's all
this chemistry that's going on we are
able to
have these chemicals interact with one
another maybe
um
have even some emergent properties that
we can quantify
definitely there is this trend towards
more systems level approach to Origins
with more introduction of systems level
chemistry or network level chemistry uh
and complex system integration in order
to understand how now that we can make
these building blocks we can make them
interact with one another but how do we
make them interact with one another in
more intelligent ways that will
have the properties of a biological
system will be heritable it will be
responding to the environment it will
mutate and it will sustain itself
that is the final bit I think in in our
origin of Life Adventure and we are
extremely close I I'm very optimistic
that our community will get a handle of
this problem in in this decade this is
in fact I think one of the most exciting
times to be doing this work what would
be super convincing to you like
incredibly amazing would blow your mind
if it was done
X was done in a lab like what
would yeah I mean I don't know if you
would call it origin of life but
something really truly remarkable and
special done in the lab what would that
look like to you the the properties that
I listed this was five properties that I
listed about in the Machinery that is
capable of sensing and responding the
environment if we can
um I would imagine it's similar to
Amelia experiments where they
on the sparked in a particular
environmental forces and were able to
produce a chemical that is important for
life or a mix of chemicals important for
life or building blocks rather I would
if I saw that a similar experiment that
and well-defined geochemical perimeter
was subjected on a mix of chemistry
which led that chemistry to form some
level of computation informatic
biological property and by biological
I'm going to keep it to very minimum
as I defined early on
um that would be super exciting to me is
self-organizing chemistry that we can
create experimentally in a flask by
simulating the conditions of early Earth
radiation be it temperature or mix of
both
that would be very cool and doing all
the five the the chemical physical
informatic computational biology yes
so like simulation and a computer would
not no would not be good it would be
great because it's they help to
understand the parameters
maybe formulate maybe quantify create
models But ultimately you need to
experiment unless it's quantum
mechanical simulation but that's going
to be extremely difficult so simulating
from the physics up that's going to be
very because you're gonna have to
simulate
the the physical the chemical the
informatic I mean honestly it's it's
very start to it's very difficult to
start the quantum mechanics and end up
in biology all through simulation but
the stuff that deepminded with Alpha
fold and protein folding is really
inspiring it's a
it's inspiring in that you're able to do
to solve a difficult biology yeah
absolutely that's that's why there's
definitely a lot of benefits to those
models predictions because they at least
help the experiment experimentalists to
come up with the priors and parameterize
things better maybe eliminates very
obvious dead ends early on given that
experiments take such a long time and
it's a huge investment
um and no one's a better experimentalist
than nature so let me let me ask you
perhaps a depressing sad for you
question really want to make me sad
you're not going to win no I know
there's a flame of optimism in you that
will never be extinguished